the Philippines is accusing China's
Coast Guard of firing a water cannon at
one of its Supply boats The Vessel was
in a routine troop rotation mission in
the South China Sea the Philippine Navy
says it happened near a submerged Reef a
handful of its troops lived there on a
rusty World War II era U.S ship
well the latest encounter took place
near the second Thomas Shoal it's a
submerged Reef that China says it has
indisputable sovereignty over the
so-called nine-dash line marks beijing's
claim over nearly the entire South China
Sea but that's disputed by other
countries in the region a 2016 un
tribunal ruling said beijing's claims
were groundless
Colonel Ray Powell is the sea light
director at the guardian notes Center
for national security innovation at
Stanford University he's joining us live
from Donna city in the Philippines so
thank you very much indeed for being
with us on Al Jazeera what is China
trying to achieve with these
provocations they don't seem to be
forcing foreign governments to change
their strategy in a broad sense
uh no Robin thanks it's a pleasure to be
with you it's uh it really has not
seemed to work in terms of trying to
bring Manila in line uh since the
beginning of the year the Philippines
has been pushing back more strongly
against uh China's blockade of second
Thomas Scholl and been publicizing uh
China's Gray Zone activities in what
they call the West Philippine Sea and
China has continued to escalate and the
Philippines has not uh back down rightly
now I mentioned that you were the sea
light director
um at the guardian not Center I we
should explain that that is a system if
I understand it correctly correct me if
I'm wrong but this is a system
essentially for monitoring movements
within a particular area of sea that
don't necessarily get tracked on
um more sort of public sites shall we
say would that be correct if I got that
right okay
um yeah that's correct you have sorry to
interrupt but I was just going to
briefly say
um we report on these incidents when
they happen and obviously they become
big news around the world but how often
do incidents like this happen
uh well I'd say there's been an incident
every rotation uh really since the
beginning of the year beginning with in
February there was a laser pointing
incident what we call a dazzler at the
Philippine resupply uh Coast Guard
vessel uh there have been a couple of
blockades uh where the Philippine Vessel
has been physically blocked uh and this
is the first of the water cannon events
this year so it's it's been pretty
routine on these resupply missions that
happened about every 45 days what would
be a Tipping Point do you think of which
sporadic provocations like these or
would become a serious threat and things
could escalate
aside from just you know a
a collision of some sort I would say
probably the most serious threat is that
something happens to make the uh the
derelict chip you referred to that is
the Philippines Outpost and second
Thomas Scholl uninhabitable uh perhaps
the ship begins to break up and slide
into the sea this really is China's
strategy which is to blockade the
Philippines away from the ship until it
becomes uninhabitable and this would
truly provoke a crisis because at that
point if the Philippines abandons the
ship uh China wins it wins the Shoal and
that would would certainly bring us into
quite a new space it's really
interesting to get your thoughts on this
Colonel Paul thank you very much Andy
for being with us and Al jazeer sir
thank you